Loum Johnny Depp today we're gonna
review the movie Jabby go a night for
black mass yeah okay we're gonna review
black nasty
yeah so there's a lot of things I like
about this movie there's a lot of things
I don't really like about this movie we
actually took the time to check out what
Shamu has had to say what Chris stuckman
had to say and what Jeremy Jones had to
say for the most part I agree with them
I don't fully agree what do you feel I
agree with pretty much most of what was
being said I think that I'm definitely
in the camp of wow that was a great
performance by Johnny Depp the movie in
my opinion felt like it forgot who its
main character was for most of the time
most of the film was John Connelly going
no no Bulger's giving us Intel that's
that's what like John Connelly John
Connelly is the FBI guy
oh yeah joel edgerton whatever his name
i know them by their real name okay i
was looking at the character that's what
it felt like most of the movie was to me
it didn't feel like it really went
anywhere it was like last year I bought
a car and in February
I bought some blu-rays then in June I
made a computer on Tuesday I worked end
of the movie it's like wait what was
this about exactly I don't understand
what any of this really has to do with
anything it's just like it's not a movie
because a movie has a story this doesn't
have a story it's just a collection of
events yeah it's like a series of events
that play out what I found weird was
it's a mob movie but yet the mob stuff
didn't really appeal to me in this film
I like the scenes where it was like
emotional tension or something like
Johnny Depp intimidating someone or
scaring the [ __ ] out of someone like
that scene with Johnny Depp and Dakota
Johnson in the hospital like that was a
great moment they have when they're
talking about their kid but then it just
does this time lapse on this minute and
I didn't like how they do that like it
would get it would get this part of the
movie where you're like okay I see where
this story's going and then it cuts to
ten years later now we're watching a
different series of events happening
with Whitey Bulger and whatever all
those things you're talking about where
a murder is about to take place in the
film is undermined by the music that's
one thing that I didn't see other people
complaining about was the music I feel
like the music got in the way it hinted
too much at what was about to happen
whereas in something like Goodfellas it
just happens and it catches you so off
guard which kind of happened once in the
movie but the rest of the time it's like
musics building up to a crescendo and
then a murder and like come on you're
giving it away because Johnny Depp does
make this movie it's a really special to
me cos giant F is one of my favorite
actors
and he has so let me down over the past
few years and to see him back in a real
role was so rewarding for me so that's
the main reason I recommend it is just
because of Johnny Depp's performance but
you're right about the music because
there are certain moments where I was
like I wouldn't have expected him to
lose his [ __ ] if the music didn't tell
me right you know like the music does
give certain moments away that could
have been really shocking and powerful
or it calms you you know right I think
there are two options they could have
that would have been better for this
either pick a few stories that you know
resonate more with people or would have
stood out more and kind of hinge them
together better it had it would have to
have been fictionalized more this is not
like this really happened these this in
this order this these things really
happen it's like no one really gives a
[ __ ] about that they want to see a
narrative that's interesting and takes
you on a journey it's escapism that's
what it should have been and that's what
it didn't accomplish it's it's not an
emotional escaping film it's more of an
interesting film to watch or something
interesting to look at yes as opposed to
you get an emotional experience out of
it doesn't really generate much
emotionally like I walked out of the
film saying it's a good movie definitely
not great though it looks like it would
be a great film like you walk out like
everything was good look good Johnny
Depp was good this new camera angles
were doing everything was good about
Anand joel edgerton it's really good in
it too
I even like Benedict Cumberbatch a lot
at first I was distracted by his Boston
accent yeah me too the whole time every
time he was on screen I'm like mm-hmm
it's a little bit hard to get past the
British accent but I still thought he
did a really good job overall Dakota
Johnson's barely in it I thought she did
a good job
I thought Johnny Depp was barely in it
now come on now you're just being an ass
no it was it was mostly about the FBI
guy I mean let's be real yeah then most
of the movie was the FBI guy Johnny
Depp's was whirling but Johnny Depp was
more of the character that everyone kept
talking about more than naturally you do
I feel like you do see joel edgerton
more it seemed like they wanted to make
an Amadeus and they didn't succeed did
you see how my day is yeah it's all
about this other guy's perspective on
Mozart it didn't really do that and it
felt like it was also trying to be
Goodfellas or something but I didn't
really do that either it was this trying
to it was this like middle
place and it didn't quite feed one beast
over the other you know I was trying to
do too much I think it's interesting
because I know that Jack Nicholson's
character departed is based off Whitey
Bulger and I felt like they got that
down better than this movie did in the
sense that you got Jack Nicholson he
find out he's working for the FBI he's
an informant and I'm like that's
essentially why he Bulger in this movie
the most common complaint I'm hearing
especially from the YouTube critics and
I totally agree is that there's no
protagonist really everyone's just a bad
guy that we're watching and the good
guys are so minor in this story that's I
don't agree with that I think that if if
you take for instance that Jake
Gyllenhaal movie where he's a trying to
get into the news organization yeah
Nightcrawler he's a bad guy in that
movie and he's the protagonist you're
following the bag of the whole time and
yet it's riveting it's amazing to watch
you can't hand it you can't have a movie
that's completely about a bad guy and it
be successful I agree it but I feel like
if this movie had a little bit of a
clear cut to find good and bad guy it
might have worked a little bit better
like one thing Jeremy Jones was saying
which I which I was like yeah I walked
out thinking that if there is something
of a little bit of that heat element
like the cop that they introduce who's
like aiming to take down Whitey Bulger
and they show more of him like that's
what made the town work yeah and you
know like I that's what makes heat work
that's what makes a lot of movies work
where opposing characters ya know like
and I feel like we don't really got that
other than Kevin Bacon being like what
the [ __ ] are you doing you [ __ ]
that's like about as far as it goes with
the other guys stepping in and saying
something the bad guy from ant-man was
in there like way too late yeah a movie
and he could have been that character
yeah that should have been introduced to
way sooner and he was way better in that
like 10 minutes he had than I thought it
the thing that's cool about this film is
that there's so much wrong with it I
think and it's there's a lack of
emotional substance however I really
walked away really thinking about Johnny
Depp's performance and every time he's
on screen the film is interesting it's
like when he's not on stream so even
when Joel it remembers just joel
edgerton I still kind of zone out a
little bit yeah but when it was Johnny
Depp I was always really immense Tintin
like what was going on immersed and what
was going on at the time
I mean he's it's undeniable his
performance is great but it's like after
a certain point it's like okay that's
your ace that's the only interesting
part of this movie and I got a board
yes I was extremely bored during the
film to be honest like Jeremy Jones said
it's almost like Game of Thrones where
it's like okay another murder happens
like yeah that's basically how I felt
it's just this happened okay now this
happened it's like okay now what okay
now this person got murdered now it's
over I'm like well wise did any of that
happen and I'm not saying the movie
neath we had to talk about this on your
channel about violence in movies mm-hmm
but the first death that you see that
was brutal but then the rest of the
deaths were like nowhere near on level
with being that violent or disturbing to
me hmm and I feel like I you shouldn't
like it's a good way to establish how
violent this character is up front but
I'm like I feel like you should have at
least escalated the violence a little
bit more rap if you were gonna have
shocking moments like that because when
you see us especially when we're talking
about this where you're becoming numb to
the violent scenes
when the violent scenes are
progressively not getting more violent
or even going less violent and the
context doesn't really feel that strong
because of the context yeah it's just
the conex context doesn't feel that
strong you know like like in Reservoir
Dogs you don't see him chop off that
guy's ear but you feel its feel it yeah
built up to that moment yeah it seemed
like a try being a lot of mob movies and
at times it works and at times it really
doesn't it's not even that though it's
just as a story it's not cohesive it's
like you don't even know who the main
perspective is in the movie it's so
misleading at the very top you're
looking at this guy's face it's not from
Braveheart from Breaking Bad and you're
like oh okay he's in this movie yep not
heshes like in the film for like ten
minutes but he's kind of there in the
background I was wool what the hell why
was that the introduction of the movie
it was kind of like a dramatization that
you'd see in a documentary I know but
they should completely misleading
there's a saying that works they should
have shown the different perspectives
that they were gonna show throughout the
movie as opposed to just him it was
almost like the opening of Hurt Locker
there was no solid perspective on who
the movie's story was being told from if
that makes any kind of sense yeah I mean
the movie is just essentially about what
happened with Whitey Bulger that caused
him to be a fugitive that's it
in the future depart they just wrap up
in like title text there was no kinetic
energy to the film at all it was very
everyone has said it it's very stale and
kind of Hollow and that's a very
accurate assessment of the film it's
just stuff and then it's over yeah I
agree with what everyone says
I just really love John yes performance
that's the only reason I'm recommending
this movie but like I'm gonna recommend
it because of Johnny that's right one
but the question is like what could they
have done differently I think the other
thing I was gonna say earlier was that
it could have been like narcos a Netflix
series of some kind that allows you to
get in depth with each of these little
events that happened over the course of
his life yeah it's because a lot of
filmmakers are not good at covering such
a it's just like it's so many years
they're trying to cover here and those
time-lapse is just really [ __ ] with you
I don't know that's the problem of
biopics it's like sometimes I feel like
why don't they do a miniseries instead
because if you're gonna do a biopic of
like 30 to 40 years of someone's life
you should try to break it down a little
bit into like one-hour episodes rather
than just you know trying to compact it
in two hours right on paper everything
looks good yeah I mean all the
performances are there you like the
directing more than I did I'm so used to
Scorsese when it comes to Italian mob
movies I know it's not a dalian it's
Irish but still and that was missing
from the film too you didn't really see
the Italian mafia in the entire movie
even though that was a big staple in the
film there was a huge part of the whole
thing and yet you never actually see
them or yeah interact with them that was
my other issue is that the criminal
activity that was going on I was like
okay based off what Joel Edgerton and
Johnny Depp are saying they're going
places not exactly sure what they're
really telling us but they're saying
they're getting further in life but I
have no clue exactly what they're doing
it yet they're right I wish they took
Johnny Depp to different places
emotionally as opposed to just this it
was kind of a one now yeah it's a
one-note villain i mean it's great but
it's just this he's in OneNote and then
like the last half hour he gets darker
that's pretty much it just one guy and
then they're like this horrible thing
happened to him
he was never the same and I'm like
exactly who he was before I don't really
get it anyway guys yeah rating time
they come up with a rating system I give
it two and a half nipple chills
two and a half Ryan nip chills on a
scale of and two huh I give it up mmm if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe you the real rejects you can
check out the chebbi koi channel movie
discussions reactions reviews and more
and you know lightsaber fight yes yes
and you can follow both of us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine if your
true star wars fan you will watch the
lightsaber fight sorry to cut you off
periscope you cut me off the rest go on
periscope vine Instagram Twitter
Facebook and see I'm doing it for you
yeah and also we're gonna be featured at
the synagogue on Sherman Way and Van
Nuys Boulevard if you're Jewish please
come out we're gonna be doing a special
event of Jewish movies that's usually
that's our main thing that's what we
grew up on we're jus films so make sure
to tune in we're gonna vlog the event
got a lot of people with yarmulkes
coming it's a Godfather's Jewish right
if you're Jewish subscriber let me know